we're looking at what's driving millions
of americans to leave their jobs a new
government report shows that 4.3 million
people quit in december that's down
slightly from the record high of four
and a half million in november cbs news
business analyst jill schlesinger joins
us right now dollar dollar jill y'all
how you doing great all right so let's
talk about this great resignation we've
been speaking on this for
the last several months um do you think
that there is a change coming soon well
we know that the number peaked in
november was down slightly in december
but when you have more than four million
people quitting every month month after
month that does not seem to be going
away anytime soon we'll have to see
we're sort of still in the beginning
stages of this big labor market change
okay we're all calling it the great
resignation but you're giving it a new
term yes i think it's the reshuffling
because it's not as if someone goes in
and says you know like costanza i quit
and they don't have another job most of
these people are going from one job to
another so they're job changers and we
see this really early in the covid
recession people said hey i'm a
front-line worker i work let's say in
hospitality it's kind of scary maybe
i'll go to a job with better pay with
benefits and maybe with a regular
schedule like warehousing if you look at
like right before the covid recession
began in february of 2020 through the
end of last year leisure and hospitality
lost 1.2 million jobs meanwhile
warehousing up more than 200 000 jobs so
that's a reshuffling more than a
flat out i quit how is inflation
impacting the reshuffling well i think
that when people are not making enough
money to keep up with prices they're
saying wow i got to do something so this
is a real big issue like think about
this if you even just go back to that
leisure and hospitality if you're not
paying enough to get to seven percent
better then you're behind and in fact if
we look at the labor department report
from last december we say hey people
after you factor in inflation guess what
we use are actually down meanwhile
leisure and hospitality wants all those
people back wages up about 16 from a
year ago and
housing up eight percent so they're
keeping track with inflation so george
costanza didn't really uh walk away
gracefully
there's a lot of people quitting their
jobs resigning are retiring um there's
one big name recently we've been talking
about is there a way to do it the right
way not like george costanza and with
all due respect to our friends in new
england i don't think the way that tom
brady did it was great i mean you got to
thank the play the team you played for
for 20 years the company you worked for
right right here so you want to be
gracious you want to say look thank you
so much for this opportunity you want to
say let's stay in touch let's stay
connected on linkedin let's do all of
that and you want to walk away with your
head hell high give your two weeks
notice be a team player to the end you
don't want to burn any bridges is what
you're saying right oh definitely not
all right we still have a lot more to
talk about because i want to uh get your
idea on how people can walk away and
resign or quit their job without burning
those bridges yeah next time next time
all right dollar dollar jail y'all thank
you so much